si le alcanzó este martes los 5 millones
de personas vacunadas dos semanas antes
de lo que había previsto el gobierno es
decir un 26% de la población ya ha
recibido una primera dosis de la vacuna
en su mayoría la vacuna china sinovac
aunque también se está vacunando con
pzifer mientras que más de un 10% de los
chilenos es decir más de 2 millones de
chinos ya han recibido dos dosis de la
vacuna esto sitúa a chile como líder no
sólo en américa latina sino también
entre los cinco países que llevan un
mejor ritmo de vacunación del mundo
según los medios internacionales que
hacen un seguimiento de estos hechos
también la semana pasada según el
ministro enrique parís el ministro de
salud se anunciaba que chile era en esa
semana el país que vacuna va a mayor
velocidad del mundo estos datos
auspiciosos que sitúan al país en marcha
para conseguir vacunar a 15 millones de
los 19 millones de chilenos antes de
finales de junio como prometió el
gobierno se producen también en medio de
una alza significativa de los contagios
cuando se reproducen las medidas de
confinamiento por ejemplo durante los
fines de semana el 98% del país está
confinado y también a partir de este
jueves varias comunas de la región
politano y muchos dentro del país
volverán a cuarentena mientras que el
colegio médico advierte del cansancio de
los trabajadores de salud y también de
la ocupación de las camas su psique se
sitúa en un 94%